Arabella and Olympia wrote a list of recipes I should make
with all the peaches from our tree,
so I chose the easiest one to make Peach Popsicles.
I'm using three cups of my frozen
ripe peaches combined with a homemade yogurt,
cream cheese straight from the farm,
100% pasture raised raw dairy,
and then a spoonful of raw honey,
bit of vanilla
and a pinch of mineral rich sea salt is all we put into this creamy,
nutrient dense frozen treat.
I filled the popsicle molds and let those fully freeze overnight.
When I was ready to remove them from their molds,
I melted some good ingredient
dark chocolate chips with unrefined coconut oil
until it was nice and creamy.
I dunked each popsicle into the melted chocolate
and then let the chocolate set on a Parchment lined baking sheet.
They firmed up almost immediately and quickly. Thereafter.
I placed each popsicle into its own bag
so that I could store them nicely in the freezer
for the kids to have their own snacks.
These are gut friendly, low sugar,
and they're free of food dyes,
artificial flavors, and seed oils.
They're perfect for summer!